good afternoon everybody this morning I
called Bob and Jani Bergdahl and told
them that after nearly five years in
captivity their son Beau is coming home
sergeant Bergdahl has missed birthdays
and holidays and the simple moments with
family and friends which all of us take
for granted but while Bowe was gone he
was never forgotten his parents thought
about him and prayed for him every
single day as did his sister Skye who
prayed for his safe return
he wasn't forgotten by his community in
Idaho or the military which rallied to
support the Bergdahl's through thick and
thin and he wasn't forgotten by his
country because the United States of
America does not ever leave our men and
women in uniform behind this commander
in chief I am proud of the
servicemembers who recovered sergeant
Bergdahl and brought him safely out of
harm's way as usual they performed with
extraordinary courage and
professionalism and they've made their
nation proud right now our top priority
is making sure that Bo gets the care and
support that he needs and that he can be
reunited with his family as soon as
possible I'm also grateful for the
tireless work of our diplomats and for
the cooperation of the government of
Qatar in helping to secure Bo's release
we've worked for several years to
achieve this goal and earlier this week
I was able to personally thank the Emir
of Qatar for his leadership in helping
us get it done as part of this effort
the United States is transferring five
detainees from the prison in Guantanamo
Bay to Qatar the Qatari government has
given us assurances that it will put in
place measures to protect our national
security I also want to express
gratitude to the Afghan government which
has always supported our efforts to
secure Bo's release going forward the
United States will continue to support
an afghan-led process of reconciliation
which could help secure a harder and P
within a sovereign and unified
Afghanistan as I said earlier this week
we're committed to winding down the war
in Afghanistan and we are committed to
closing Gitmo but we also made an
ironclad commitment to bring our
prisoners of war home that's who we are
as Americans it's a profound obligation
within our military and today at least
in this instance it's a promise we've
been able to keep I am mindful though
that there are many trip troops who
remain missing in the past that's why
we're never going to forget we're never
going to give up our search for
servicemembers who remain unaccounted
for we also remain deeply committed to
securing the release of American
citizens who are unjustly detained
abroad and deserve to be reunited with
their families just like the Bergdahl's
soon will be bob Janney today families
across America sharing the joy that I
know you feel as a parent I can't
imagine the hardship that you guys have
gone through as president I know that I
speak for all Americans when I say we
cannot wait for the moment when you are
reunited and your son Beau is back in
your arms so with that I'd like about to
have an opportunity to say something and
Jan if she's like his wife
I just want to say thank you to everyone
who has supported Bo he's had a
wonderful team everywhere we will
continue to stay strong for bo while he
recovers
thank you I'd like to say to bo right
now who's having trouble speaking
English beats me a lot of real fun I
wreck him say ah BM I'm your father Bo
people of Afghanistan the same Khalifa
al-thani the complicated nature of this
recovery was we'll never really be
complemented comprehended to each and
every single one who effected this in
this country in the service branches at
the State Department throughout the
whole of American government and around
the world at international governments
around the world thank you so much we
just can't communicate the words this
morning when we heard from the president
so we looked forward to continuing the
recovery of our son which is going to be
a considerable task for our family and
we hope that the media will understand
that that will keep us very preoccupied
in the coming days and weeks as he gets
back home in the United States thank you
all for being here very much